when you first see the shooter shoot i
already look dirty no nobody won't bite
on a dirty shoe
but if you look closely they come dirty
what's up it's the kid gonna this
is my life is sneakers i'm live right
now from my home in atlanta and i'm
about to go over my drip with gq
if you know me you know i love clothes
you know i love to get dressed
i collect some of the top brands top
fashions and uh
right now i'm gonna show you a few rare
sneakers of mine
last lashes the flashiest [ __ ] of mine
would have to be
the nike tom sacks they speak for
themselves
they give me astronaut vibes like i'm
walking on
space at the moon i feel like they're
attention grabbers you know
like if i got these on you're gonna be
like what are those
this material right here is like i want
to say plastic
but it's stiff too it's like firm and
then the bottom is rubber
it's like rubber right here than like
leather right here
i haven't worn yet brand new
i bought them from a sneaker head this
little young cat
sells sneakers he uh live in miami he
got him for me
i didn't even pay him i just gave him a
shout out
it has like another shoe on the inside
like a whole nother shoe and then like
this like the sole of the other shoe
it looked like it would be hard it's not
though it's off
and then they nike's that's the whole
like gag
like those are nikes i actually don't
know tom said
i never met him i want to meet you
though bro i like your shoes
i'm thinking maybe like heroin preston
jacket
this same color material you gonna wash
blue denim jeans joints
light blue like these i might go white
v-neck
on the six-inch v down in my stomach
where you see my tattoos and my jewelry
yeah i go like that it got to be cold
with e so i gotta go skully maybe red
and white nike scully
i'm saying drill
rarest my rare sneaker
would have to be the v-long nikes they
like one of the craziest collabs
v-long and nike like even if they were
to release these today they'll sell out
i promise
they're never gonna get old i maybe wore
these shoes once or twice
maybe maybe they got the orange
with the black leather that real good
leather they match my lamb
truck when i drive a lamb truck i wear
these
i got these from bart himself you know
what i'm saying
mr barth v long god he gave me these
because i'm gonna be long though d
the real deal if i was to put these on i
could wear these jeans right here
my shorts show the text the louis
vuitton best version joint collab
had the black launch lead turtle eleante
turtleneck up on it
drips no cap
[Music]
most expensive my most expensive
shoe would have to be these dolce
gabbanas
they're very special because i got
nominated for a grammy
and had to go to the grammy awards and
these are the shoes i bought
i paid 2200 for them i never really seen
myself paying that much for
dress shoes because i don't really wear
dress shoes a lot
but these are special look like they got
like black like crystals on them in the
front
i had to rip orange blazer like a suit
drips
most underrated my most underrated
sneaker
would have to be these chanel pharrell i
feel like these was just like
slept on i don't see a lot of people who
have them
you never see a black person like collab
with like
a mainstream company that hadn't already
been established like
for chanel to even reach out or for car
to even just like
let that collection even be made was
like legendary to me
so i feel like people slept on it like
and didn't really understand what it was
so that's why i said it's most like
underrated because like
it's history and fashion like for this
to ever just be a collab like
for real and chanel for real has had a
big influence on fashion
from my point of view because even way
back like the eclipse like
when they was doing that he was going
bake and he was doing like
the ice cream then like and it was like
people would didn't even understand what
it was and now to this day
people are still wearing to this day for
you to have a clothing line or you to be
a face of a brand back then and that
brand is still like
relevant to this day it tells a lot he
was like one of the ones doing birkin
bags first
like that's where i got the idea from
anyway from pharrell
speaking of my bad collection like i i
love bags
that's another reason why i feel like
pharrell has like a major like
standpoint for his fashion not just
music i bought these
in toronto i think i was on tour maybe
when like
the for real like first light start
doing drops because
it was everywhere but not everywhere i
ran into this chanel store and ran into
him
i didn't even know like he had already
dropped yet caught these
a few bags few belts all right ain't
what is yet
and what it is yet when i do ready i'm
probably go like
on the real hot hot water jeans where
you can see my knees
and my tattoos and stuff no socks no
cindy knee
i got a chanel towed over bad throw that
over
i got a chanel for real t-shirt or the
chanel for a t-shirt i don't know
like like but heavy though
unexpected my most
unexpected shoot that like my fans
probably wouldn't think i had in my
closet
would be the ugg sneakers it's all
comfortable
you don't wear socks with these you wear
your feet with these
not really stylish but they still
comfortable
and like nothing beats being comfortable
and they all black
so you could throw them on just you know
what i'm saying like really like what i
got on the day
like dark black jeans gray shirt gray
inside for
the shoe you know i'm saying that's the
further inside these shoes probably cost
a hundred and twenty dollars 130 dollars
but
i really like these shoes too so
introduce me to these
he had a brown pair shh i bought a black
pair
the same day i've been buying them ever
since it's
unexpected and it's a shoe i would grab
quick and throw on because they're
comfortable
ugly but still cool these are the mason
margela fusions
these shoes are ugly but they still cool
meaning when you first see the shoe the
shoe i look dirty no no i won't buy no
dirty shoes
but if you look closely they come dirty
it's a distorted shoe like it's stylish
but it's like you can throw them on
anywhere like that
you can don't you can go to a festival
with these shoes i bought a lot of them
because i really like this shoe like you
see this right here they got a scuff
right like i bought them like that
i ain't never wore these shoes
i never wore these they got a scuff on
them in the front already
i don't know really what an ugly way
started
i took a lightning into it because like
i go overseas a lot
and when i go overseas and i'm at these
festivals
i see pretty pretty girls but they
should be dirty
and i'll be like what i wonder why but
it's like it's like a thing they like
wearing like
busted sneakers and i feel like that's
what marjella probably came with like oh
let me make a stylish busted sneaker
here you have a stylish busted sneaker
the mason margiela fusions cost about
1800
i know you like why the hell would i pay
1800 for a [ __ ] that's already dirty
that's the point i like them i feel like
they
stylish and fashionable without
like me saying it like when you put them
on and you see you don't like what are
those
but then you get up close and you see
how i put it on without for you like
it's kind of crazy i own a few of these
there's another pair these are actually
wore like this is slime green so i went
slime green sweatpants with them
i threw the slime green like like
turtleneck up on them
then i went slime green and white mason
margiela like
over like light coat over it drips
ugly but cool promise
bonus shoe bonus i wasn't supposed to
show y'all this [ __ ] but i'ma show it to
you
you may be seeing them maybe not my own
shoe like customly made from puma
i didn't go put my name on them puma put
the name on for me
these are very special to me i never did
nothing like this before
this was my first time ever getting a
shoe like made with my name on it by
real company it's something i'm i'ma
always remember this is my custom
sneaker
from porn they put this line green for
me you know saying french line
you know what i'm saying yeah they got
the black and gray i really made the
colorway
me and alexander john this designer from
atlanta
we collabed on it and made this come to
life
thank you alexander by the way and thank
you pumu i appreciate you guys
this was our first of many
so yeah that's a wrap i appreciate
everyone coming to check out my shoe
collection
shout out all my fans go download wanna
is out right now
yeah slap business
i'm just gonna be real with you